right now
um I can't give you an answer on
marriage I'm not ready to marry anyone
I mean after having lunch with my mom it
reinforced me that Liz and I need to
take it slow we're just not ready I'm
not ready and she's not ready us getting
married right now would literally be a
contract for a divorce with all the
issues that we need to work through
still
I'm just not ready I don't
I know but it is something that as I'm
thinking about the future and now like
wanting to be secure not I am not going
to be pressured into getting married
I am not ready
I was just saying I would like to think
or talk or anything like ready
I don't feel like I'm being heard you
are being hurt I don't feel like I'm
being heard would you shut up so I can
explain to you that you were heard the
fact that I'm getting angry how okay you
know what I'm sorry for telling you to
shut up
I'm not telling you I don't want to
marry you
baby I'm not saying that I'm just not
ready
I'm just saying that you
I'm not ready to get married I don't
know when I will I'm just not ready to
get married
Ed proposed to me and I want a life with
Ed and maybe now it is coming to an
ultimatum on my end he's got to be all
in or not at all because all I hear is
excuse after excuse
I'm really tired of not getting anywhere
with him and our relationship and I
think Ed and I are too different to make
this work long term and
[Music]
I've dealt with a lot to stick by his
side and I don't deserve the drama
anymore I don't deserve the Heartbreak I
don't deserve I don't deserve it anymore
[Music]
[Music]
foreign